uh when are you getting this uh when are  we getting the album  um man I was trying to you know we was  trying to get it out this year but uh  with samples and stuff you know how that  goes yeah and it's like really if you  don't get it out by like next Friday  there's no point I mean the music  industry shuts down right you guys are  on vacation  it's it's really kind of hard to put it  out now December exactly and get like  the full impact that you wanted to have  you know so uh you know top top of 20 to  February something like that probably  February yeah I'm like people come back  from vacation like January 6th oh yeah  yeah we'll see so February we'll see I'm  open to either all right January  February March it'll be February or more  April I don't know about January  January's also still kind of shaky  everyone's coming back from vacant you  know how the music industry is we're  letting people behind the curtain a  little here yeah